Dr. Thomas Seafried speaks a lot on metabolic cancer and claims he has tested all the major
types of cancer. It has determined that they all feed on a combination of glucose and glutamine.
He advocates clinical ketosis and push pulse therapy for short duration glutamine inhibitor
to kill off cancer cells. He also says also low dose chemo can be used once in clinical ketosis.
I know you say that some cancers are not based on this fermentation process. What are your thoughts
on this approach? Sounds like a combination with your protocols or with rife doesn't seem like
considered by standards of care, even though there seems to be strong significant evidence
of cancer as a metabolic disease. What are your thoughts? So he's the guy who wrote cancer as a
metabolic disease. Now understand to define that, you know, just because cancer, so metabolic disease
means that really every disease is a metabolic disease except diseases that are specifically
genetic cause of which like if you're born with down syndrome or something, that's not a metabolic
disorder. You can't change a person's diet and change their down syndrome. So of course every acquired
disease is metabolic in origin. Now he just kind of coined that phrase, cancer is a metabolic disease.
Nobody argued that it wasn't. There are some cancers that are genetic, but it's a very small
percentage of the cancers that are genetic. So when a person says, well, cancer is a metabolic disease,
so you need to use ketosis, you know, in a ketogenic diet to treat it. You're not equating one
and one there just because he wrote that book, he advocates for ketogenic diet. Doesn't mean that a
ketogenic diet is going to solve every metabolic disorder. So a metabolic disorder means a disorder
of cellular function. So of course every disease is a disorder of cellular function. Now I would agree
with him that, you know, most cancers feed on glucose and glutamine and can switch back and forth.
So I would agree that that is the case. The truth is all your cells feed on glucose through glycolysis.
They also can feed on fatty acid cycle, because cell's purpose is to make energy. So you need to
make energy in order for cellular functions to take place. So a cell's purpose is to make ATP.
So that's the energy that a cell makes. Most efficient ways to make ATP is through glucose,
metabolism, breaking it down through glycolysis and then through the crab cycle where it really kicks
on ATP. Also, you could break down amino acids, also fatty acids. So cancer can feed any
different way. The truth is cancer is going to do everything it can to feed any different way.
So it will change. So is it wrong to go out of ketogenic diet? No, it can be very beneficial to go
out of ketogenic diet. Does a person need to get in ketosis in order to shut down the glucose pathway?
No, that's not true either. But the closer you could get to ketosis, the lower your glucose level,
you could get the lower levels of circulating glucose that you could have. The benefit is going
to be that the truth is nobody's ever going to have no glucose. You need glucose. Your brain is
always going to need to feed off of glucose. So if you didn't have any glucose, you would die.
But you don't want to supply excess glucose to cancer. So you don't want to supply excess
you will to a cancer cell. Whether it's glucose or glutamate or amino acids or fatty acids or whatever
that cancer has acquired a taste or to feed off of. So diet is important for cancer. So I would agree
when you say that standards of care doesn't seem to address this issue. I would totally agree with
standards of care doesn't really address any metabolic disease. Standards of care really
doesn't address any chronic disorders well. They don't deal with diet. You see the
rebergerator in a chemo center loaded with putting in, you know, they recommend high sugar drinks
because they have a high caloric count. It's just foolishness what standards of care does.
Certainly switching between a ketogenic type diet and switching, trying to do things to
lower glutamate levels and methionate levels can be very beneficial. And everybody's going to
find what's going to be best for their cancer if they don't have a way to test for that.